all right and it is medicare monday
according to medicare by ama the
sponsors of this next segment it's that
time of year again and they have a local
resource center to help you out
so we're talking about medicare we are
back
here now it is that time of year um so
just introduce us to medicare by ama
what you guys do for the community we're
an agency here really to help our
medicare eligible communities so anybody
eligible to be on medicare we're here to
help we're here to give them that
information that education that's going
to help them with their medicare choices
for this upcoming annual enrollment
period
and speaking of enrollment period what
is that time frame
this is very important
absolutely yeah that time frame every
year is october 15th october 15th is a
start date until december 7th this is
when anybody or any medicare eligible
person can make a change to their
medicare advantage or prescription drug
plan but not only that we're here to
help provide that education medicare can
be confusing and we're here to help all
of those
people those clients that receive
medicare
help them understand how things work
so why do you think it's so important
for the local medicare eligible to have
these services and to and to really
educate or be educated on what medicare
is
great question i get this asked all the
time so as you probably see on tv now
there's so many different communication
pieces there's so many national
tv ads call this number call this
also all of our medicare eligibles get
so much information in the mail it can
be confusing it is confusing things
change every year as well so we like to
make sure we can give them that help
that support that education on not only
the new plans that are coming in because
every year those new plans come in from
october 15th and they start in january
but also help them understand what they
have and more importantly help them save
money in their pockets and this is why
you guys hold medicare mondays right um
they're going to be at our medicare
resource center there at 10 a.m
every single monday and this is just
where we are gonna talk all things
medicare we're gonna do a medicare 101
presentation and help our medicare
eligibles local
to las vegas understand more how
medicare works anyone who is medicare
eligible can look into that and how can
they get more information they can get
more information by dropping by we're
open six days a week
nine till five um at our resource center
which is on tropicana and eastern it's
2250
east tropicana really excited that's a
brand new location we have as well for
this year so that's super exciting uh we
have our medicare mondays they can drop
by any day
or they can actually email or call us as
well and i know those details will be at
the bottom of the screen there
thank you medicare by ama for sponsoring
that segment the resource center is open
nine to five pm monday through saturday
give them a call at 702-330-0264
or visit
medicarebyama.com and you can join their
medicare monday every monday at 10 a.m
through december 7th to find out how you
can get the most out of your medicare
plan we'll be right back right here on
las vegas now